source code yeah I got nothing to be
honest Jake Gyllenhaal and Michelle
monogamy monoghan I'm not sure as usual
at Jeffrey Wright and Vera Farmiga star
in source code a thriller that's about a
new piece of technology that allows you
to go into someone's body eight minutes
before they die and try to figure out
what's going on for the doc Jake
Gyllenhaal is forced to be in the body
of someone who's about to blow up on a
train and his mission is to figure out
who the bomber is and tried to avert a
second bomb that's supposedly going to
happen using the information that he's
able to discover on this train
and he has many tries to do it as you
can but they are running out of time
basically it's a pretty much non-stop
action thriller extracted by Duncan
Jones who directed moon which I very
much enjoyed a magnificent forints by
Sam Rockwell and I knew when I first saw
that movie that the director was going
somewhere I really enjoyed this movie it
was a lot of fun Jake Gyllenhaal was
really great as the main character and I
actually really liked Michelle also she
did a very nice job she's very pretty
actually you're affirming it was good as
always
however Jeffrey Wright who I usually
like I feel just completely over acting
throughout this entire film and his
character really annoyed me
I mean his character was kind of
supposed to be annoying but he over
acted so much he was like look at me I'm
Jeffrey Wright so I have a giant black
beard now there's some really good
action scenes in this film a lot of
sustained tension for a large portion of
the movie some really good images too
and good special effects and not overuse
special effects which is very good and
very important to me because whenever
director uses special effects of the
crutch probably not going to work out
well think of Matrix Reloaded all the
scenes where neo is fighting all those
Smith's it is so obvious whenever
there's a special affection I mean it's
so fake neo like hopping along the heads
of all the Smiths and on that here the
special effects are using the similar
use effectively and use sparingly and
that's something I really enjoyed I
really liked how has Jake continued to
have to go through the scenario over and
over and over again he became completely
familiar with all the things that
happened he was able to turn that on the
passengers like as the passenger is
about to walk by and spill he's like
don't spill that don't answer that phone
hey I know exactly what you're about to
do and it more for a lot of good comedy
this movie was actually very hyped
really good ratings on Rotten Tomatoes
and to be honest I feel it's a little
overrated I found this to be a fun
action movie but really nothing more
than that a lot of it is so fast-paced
that it's really kind of hard to get
attached a lot of it just kind of boom
happens so quickly and just kind of
starts right from the beginning here in
this situation they don't have a lot of
time to ease into the film to ease into
the characters lives and so it makes for
kind of a rushed feeling I think maybe
if the film's start out a little bit
slower and then got into the situation
they might have had a little more depth
with the characters and I would have
been a little more entertaining I still
enjoyed the film it was a fun movie I
would recommend seeing it and just
expect a fun action ride it's pretty
much non-stop from beginning Dan you
start to really like Jake's character a
lot you feel for him he's a very good
actor and I like him in everything he
does it's a fun action movie and I would
definitely recommend seeing three out of
four stars for source code
it has like 87 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes but I mean inception has like a
86 or something I mean yeah like the
main rating is like average of seven
point four out of the ten which means
that you know it's more like 74 percent
but still I'm a dork for rotten tomatoes
by the way